Okay, so we want to pick up at September the 8th, 1905.
True charity or true love is to do good to one's neighbor because he's an image of God.
Now, notice that the heading says that the intention with which you love somebody is
extremely important. As I was in my usual state, "Blessed Jesus came for just a
little," and he told me, "my daughter, true charity or true love is when in doing
good to one's neighbor, one does it because that person is my image." That is
Genesis 1, 27, made in the image of God. And Romans 8, 29, we become images
of Christ. Genesis 1, 27, and Romans 8, 29. All the charity or love that goes
out of this sphere cannot be called charity. If the soul wants the merit of
charity, she must never go out of this sphere of looking at my image in
everything. Now, since we're on volume 6, you will have already heard Louisa
interceding for the mitigation of chastisements and she'd say, "They are
your images." She'd actually say those words. Okay. It's so true that true
charity consists in this, that my very charity never goes out of this sphere. I
only love the human creature because she's in my image. And if my sin, she
deforms this image of mine, I no longer feel like loving her. On the country, I
abhor her. And I only preserve plants and animals because they serve my images. And
the soul must modify all of herself on the example of our Creator. You see, we
can have a motivation that we will be nice to someone because they're related
to us or they're our friend or we like them. Now, Jesus is saying, "For someone in
the divine will, that's not acceptable. You must love everyone you meet on the
same level that this person has been created in the image of God." And that
would change your attitude to lots of people. Okay. I remember a person saying
to me once that she was walking up to Holy Communion one Sunday morning and
all of a sudden the Lord said, "Stop. Sit down." And she was completely shocked.
And she sat down and she said, "Lord, what have I done?" And he said, "You hate
someone I love." And she said, "Me." And so the Lord gave her the name and it was
the name of a politician. Okay. And she said, "They're only a politician." He said,
"That person was created in my image and I paid for their redemption. Do you mind?"
If you don't want to change your attitude to that person, he said, "Don't come up
for communion because you're not in communion with me." Now, he could only say
that to somebody who's walking a serious spiritual life because nobody else would
understand, would they? But he said it to her very strongly and I only know
because she told me in her shock. And I said, "Yeah, I can go tell that story but
not indicating who it is." Okay. And if we if we love everybody because they are
made in the image of God and that God's own love and grace is flowing into them
and that Jesus paid fully for their redemption, it would change the way we
relate to them, wouldn't it? And we would have respect and honor for
everybody whether they deserved it or not. Okay. So, September the 17th, 1905, how we
can participate in the sorrows of our blessed mother. This is very good.
Having been in much suffering because of the privation of my most sweet Jesus
this morning, the day of our Lady of sorrows was come. After I struggled in
some way, he came and told me, "My daughter, what do you want? That you so much
yearn for me?" And Louisa said, "Lord, what you have for yourself, that is that I
yearn for myself." And he said, "My daughter, for myself, I have thorns, nails,
and cross." And Louisa said, "Well then, that's what I want for myself." And he
gave me his crown of thorns and shared with me the pains of the cross. Now you
see there that true love wants identification with the beloved. That's
real love. Unfortunately, many people today and enter into what they call a
marriage bond. And all they're looking for is for the other person to satisfy
their needs. Does that make sense? That's not marriage. Marriage is a going out of
oneself to another person to give them life. Because that's what love is. And that
kind of love, if it was reciprocated, would make an incredible sign on the
earth. Absolutely incredible. Okay. So there's Louisa looking for identification
and Jesus said, "All I have are nails and cross." And he said, "She said, 'Right, I'll
have them.'" Notice her bravery. She doesn't pull back from this. Then he added,
"Everyone can share in the merits and in the goods produced by the sorrows of
my mother. One who in advance places herself in the hands of providence,
offering herself to suffer any kinds of pains, misery, illnesses, calamities, and
everything which the Lord will dispose for her, comes to participate in the first
sorrow of the prophecy of Simeon." Now can I read that again so you know the
standard? In case you think you're on the rung of the letter. Anyone who said, "Who in
advance places herself in the hands of providence, offering herself to suffer
any kind of pains, miseries, illnesses, calamities, and everything which the
Lord will dispose for her, comes to participate in the first sorrow of our
blessed mother." There's six more. How are you doing? I'm already gone. Don't know
about you. Okay. "One who actually finds herself amid sufferings and is resigned,
clings more tightly to me and does not offend me. It is as if she were saving
me from the hands of Herod, keeping me safe and sound within the Egypt of our
heart, and she participates in the second sorrow." You probably have managed that
a little bit, have you? "One who feels downhearted, dry and deprived of my
presence and remains yet firm and faithful to her usual practices, even more she
takes the opportunity to love me and to search for me more, without tiring, comes
to participate in the merits and goods which my mother acquired when I was lost.
One who in any circumstance that she encounters, especially in seeing me
gravely offended, despised, trampled upon, tries to repair me to
compassionate me and to pray for the very ones who offend me. It is as if I
encountered that soul, the soul of my mother, who if she could have done it would
have freed me from my enemies and she participates in the fourth sorrow. "One
who crucifies her senses for love of my crucifixion and tries to copy the
virtues of my crucifixion within herself participates in the fifth sorrow. One who
is in a continuous attitude of adoring and kissing my wounds, repairing and
thanking me in the name of all mankind, as it is as if she were holding me in her
arms, just as my mother helped me when I was deposed from the cross, she
participates in the sixth sorrow. One who remains in my grace and corresponds to
it, giving a place to no one else but me in her heart, it is as if she buried me
in the center of her heart and she participates in the seventh sorrow. Now
give yourself marks one to ten for each one of them, okay, and then you'll know
how far you've got in this thing because it's only when Jesus will give
something like that that you realize the standard is incredibly high, isn't it?
And we're inclined to let ourselves off the hook an awful lot easier than that.
If it's any help here, when I've read that I give myself zero out of ten for the
whole seven of them, I don't know about you. And I just said, Lord, you know, I'm
a miserable one, I've got to start at the beginning because you might as well
be truthful about it and not pretend that we're somewhere where we're not, you
know. So October the 10th 1905, the sign that the soul is perfectly clasped and
united with Jesus is that she is united with all neighbors. Now the little word
there that is difficult is the word all. Okay, we're all united to some neighbors.
Okay, and of course neighbor means every human being on the planet. It doesn't
just mean the ones living next door here. While I was very afflicted because of
the struggles the blessed Jesus made me suffer in waiting for him this morning,
making himself seen for just a little he told me, my daughter, I feel sorry for
the sorrow and for seeing you as though immersed in bitter affliction because of
my privation. I feel such pain because of your affliction, especially since it is
because of me. And I feel as if it were my own. Now most people looking at that
would say, but you're the very one who could stop it. All you've got to do is go
back to Louisa and everything is hunky dory. Okay, what are you doing standing
back saying that you also are suffering? I'm trying to give you a way of helping
you to examine the text and to ask questions. At those of you who will join
the divine will family, you will be taught how to ask the right questions of the
text and then all of a sudden the text opens up to you. Okay, because sometimes
we're inclined to just take it and keep moving you know instead of stopping and
saying, but he could have changed that. Why did he change it? Because if you ask
that question, then you can go searching for an answer. But if you don't ask the
question, you can't go searching for an answer because there isn't a question in
your head. This is what I'm saying. So you will be taught how to ask the
questions. So I feel as if it were my own and it is so great that of all the
afflictions of others were united together. They would not give me as much
appearance pain as yours alone because Louisa wants more than all the other
people on the planet. For it is only because of me. Therefore, would you show
me your cheerful face? Make me see that you are content, huh? Do you get it? He's
saying you're causing me pain. So would you ever put a smile on your face and
stop increasing my pain? You see, but excuse me Lord, I just told you that you're
the cause of it and you could solve it. But he's the husband that won't accept
that. I know you don't have husbands like that. You're great ones. Two Corinthians
nine seven. Two Corinthians nine seven. Okay, show me your cheerful face. No two
Corinthians nine seven is God only loves cheerful givers. He doesn't like sad
saints at all. Then he clasped himself tightly with me and said the sign that
the soul is perfectly clasped and united to me is that she is united with all of
her neighbors. Oops. Now notice he's changed the subject. That's Proverbs 15
13. Just as no clashing or disordered notes must exist with those who are
visible on the earth. So no clashing note of disunion exists with the invisible
God. John 15 nine. There must be total love. Jesus said in John 15 nine as the
father has loved me. So in the same way I love you. And because of that, this is
the way you must love one another with divine love. That's what he was saying
in John 15 nine. Now notice the issue of Lord you're causing me pain by your
privation wasn't answered. Okay. And the reason for that is that Jesus is
answered it many times before now. That is a way chastising. And sometimes she
really comes up to the mark and she's able to offer it and and all the rest of
it. But then she falls back into our usual thing. It's very like us. That one
day we really we do the right thing and all the other. And then a week later we
say, Oh my God, I've forgotten all about it. You're not like that. Okay. So welcome
to the human race. October the 12th, the 1905. The knowledge of self empties the
soul of herself and fills her with God. Put a VIP on this. This is extremely
important. Whether you're in the divine will or whether you're in ordinary
spirituality. This is extremely important. The scriptures tell us that
knowledge of self is the first step on the letter. Okay, let me illustrate
knowledge of self. Supposing all of us were living in community. And I was one
of these touchy porcupines that you couldn't say voodoo or ghost to because
she'd react every time. What happens is that all of you are suffering from that
is not right. And you're all having to mind your peace and cues. But the only
person in the entire group who needs the information is me. And if I get the
information in such a way that I begin to take on board that I'm causing all of
you pain and struggle because of my reactions, then that's the stimulus for
me to change. Did you get it? That's self knowledge that you actually come to
understand something that you're doing. How it's affecting others. Okay. And if you
ever get to the stage of going to confession and saying, I did such and
such because it's the because is extremely important. I did it for this
reason. Because the priest is used to hearing people saying I did or said
certain such thing or whatever. But he's not used to somebody having the self
knowledge to say I did it because then he knows how to advise me because he
knows what's behind it. Do you see what I'm saying? And he can help me to
eradicate it completely. If I say I said something nasty to this neighbor here
because I wanted to get my own back on him, he has hurt me. Then the priest knows
that my sin is revenge. Do you see the problem? It's the because that made the
difference. I wanted to give him a piece of my mind. That means I want to get
even. That's revenge. Okay. So if he knows the sin is revenge, it's not what I
would have confessed if I didn't tell him that. Do you see what I'm saying? If I
merely said I said words I shouldn't say. The priest isn't hearing that this
person has committed a sin called revenge, which is a serious sin. Okay. And that's
why what I call the because is actually very important. Okay. So this is knowledge
of self. This is a very important thing. Continue in my usual state. Blessed Jesus
came for just a little and he told me, my daughter, the knowledge of self empties
the soul of herself and fills her with God because when we realize that
something, some attitude that we have or some reaction that we have is not only
damaging to others, it's also damaging to yourself. And that is the stimulus that
makes you convert to love. And the first thing that happens to you is that you go
into humility. Now to really walk in the divine will, you've got to go way beyond
humility into nothingness. I think it's the most brilliant thing in the divine
will just go into your nothingness because that leaves the Lord completely
free. Okay. And so the knowledge of self empties the soul of herself and
fills herself with God. Now self knowledge also enables you to be truly
repentant and Jesus will tell you in these writings that there are people
going to confession who are not repentant and therefore the absolution isn't
valid because they know they're going to go back and do what they did. So they're
not really repentant. Not only this, but this in the soul, there are many
receptacles and everything that can be seen in the world takes its place in
these receptacles, something more something less according to the concept
of them that she makes for herself. That's what you call internalizing worldly
stuff. Okay. Now the soul who knows herself is filled with God knowing that
she is a nothing or rather a fragile rotten and stinking vase is well wary
of letting more filthy rot enter into her interior which is the things that can
be seen in the world. So beside that I want you to put Sam 8, Lord what is man
that you would even be mindful of him or the son of man that you would care for
him and yet you've made him a little less than a God and crowned him with
glory and honor. So what you're being told here is that as we enter more and
more into self-knowledge we become more and more wary of damage that can come
to us from the world, from outside. One who had a rotten wound and kept
gathering more rot to put in the wound would be quite crazy. Right? Now the
knowledge of self brings with it the knowledge of the things of the world and
therefore how everything is vanity and fleetingness, goods that are only masked
deceit in constancy of the creature. Now you know the beginning of the book of
Ecclesiastes, vanity of vanities, and all is vanities. So that's E-C-C-L-E-S-1-1.
Ecclesiastes chapter 1 and verse 1, vanity of vanities and all is vanity. So
knowing how things are in themselves is well aware of letting them enter
into our self and so all these receptacles remain filled with the
virtues and God, Ephesians 4-7, Ephesians 4-7 and Romans 8-20.
Now at this point that a person becomes very attentive. If you know the damage
that a particular sin has done to you and to others you'll be very attentive in
the future and watch that space as we say. Ok so October the 16th, 1905, the closer
the soul draws to the love of God the more she loses her own virtues. Now one
of the problems, one of the many myriad problems we have in the world is that
people tell you to assert yourself and to sell yourself and if you have
something flaunted before the world, in other words you are advertising
yourself, you're praising yourself, you're glorifying yourself in front of the
world. Ok and whatever your advantages or features are that's what you
actually project on to other people, that's the exact opposite in the
spiritual life. That's why a truly worldly person and a truly spiritual
person have no conversation in common. They're actually operating on exactly
opposite principles and the worldly person will get it rather quickly that
they can't communicate with you. Ok and the person trying to live the spiritual
life will have the experience that I don't know how to communicate with this
person. Have you ever had that? Yes. I don't have words that this person would
understand that's very common for anyone trying to live a spiritual life. That
means you're on completely different platforms operating on entirely
different principles and there is no nothing to bridge the gulf. All you can
do for that person is pray and interesting and do penance for them. So
now another thing you can do. So now we're going to get the most wonderful
dissertation about love. This is the triumph of love. So the the whole 36
volumes is divine will and love. Ok so Louisa says having read a book which
dealt with the virtues I was concerned in looking at myself but I could see no
virtue in me. Now Louisa has been trained by Jesus not to look at herself
to only look at him and if you want to make progress look at him and if
something in you needs to change he'll tell you he'll make it obvious or he'll
get one of God's little helpers to come and tell you except they won't tell you
as nicely as he would and they love multiplying it by ten. You always do
this or you never do that. You've never had anything like that you haven't you
know. God's little helpers multiply it so all you have to do is they take the
kernel and give them the division or the multiplication. Ok when God does it he
does it so delicately that you're in danger of not hearing it because God is
is refined love human beings aren't. So there was Louisa and she couldn't find
any virtue in herself because she's been trained to look at God. Now you need to
know the environment she's in. It's 1905. It's more than a century ago and in the
church particularly in religious life it was terribly important that you practice
virtue and that was so up to recent times as well. I remember somebody who
didn't like me telling me that she was practicing charity on me. It's how to
feel nice in one easy lesson. I told her if she didn't coach I'd be
practicing murder on her. Human beings have a most extraordinary form of
communication. We use the sword all the time. You know what I mean? We don't use
the kid loves and only only the divine hand can actually teach us how to use
kid loves dealing with people because they're just as wounded as we are. Do you
know what I mean? But in those days you know your practiced charity therefore you
found somebody you didn't like and you practiced charity under and you found
somebody that irritated you like hell and you practiced patience under. This was
called getting the virtues. I would think it was getting insanity but never
mind. Anyway so Louisa's reading this kind of stuff in a book okay and she
says God I haven't done any virtues. I don't think like that and anyway she hasn't
any neighbors to bump into it. She's in a bed. So if it wasn't that I just want to
love Jesus and that I want him and that I love him and I want to be loved by
blessed Jesus nothing nothing of God would exist in me. Now she doesn't know you
see that she's hit the jackpot. This is the center. This is it and these others
that are talking about various virtues don't know what she's talking about. So
now as I was in my usual state that means of ecstasy. My adorable Jesus told
me my daughter. The closer the soul comes to the end what's the end. So as to draw
near the fount of every good which is the true and perfect love of God that means
the end is the height of the spiritual life. You come to the summit of the
spiritual life. In these writings the height of sanctity is what we would call
the summit of sanctity like the summit of a mountain okay. So which is true and
perfect love of God in which everything will remain submerged and love alone
will float. That's exactly where Louisa is and she doesn't realize it. So on one
side you need to put Ephesians 3 16 to 21 growing and in love and on the other
side Deuteronomy 6 4 to 10 loving God. I suppose I should give you Matthew 22
22. Now what are the verses? Can't remember the verses but Jesus said that
loving God and your neighbor the entire scripture hangs on those two laws.
Remember so it's in Matthew 22. Yeah and it won't be hard to find because it's
it's one of the major themes in Matthew 10 20. It should be after verse 20 I
think. So everything is submerged and love alone will float. In other words the
only thing that's the issue then is love. To be the engine of everything so that
means love is the motivation for everything. The more she loses all the
virtues she has practiced along the journey that means that you're no
longer aware of the fact that you're being patient or that you're being
kind or that you're being humble or that you're being distant the other
because you're not concentrating on that you're concentrating on the essence of
the thing. That's like saying someone is in for the Olympic gold medal and they
keep their eyes on the gold they're not looking at anything before that. The ones
who look at things before that are not going to get there okay. So she
loses or forgets all of that stuff to enclose everything in love. That's your
one Corinthians 14 one you must want love more than anything else. And she
rests from everything that means all your struggles about being patient and
kind and all the rest of it they all rest to love only. John 14 one. So in
other words when you get to the heights of the spiritual life there's only one
issue and it's love because God is love and if I can use Ryanair language when
you get on the ship to go home you can only take hand baggage and the hand
baggage has L O V E on it. Anything else weighs too much even the human virtues
weigh too much. The only thing that can be airborne is love. The only thing that
gets into heaven is love because heaven is all about love okay. So all the things
that we find difficult down here are all opportunities for us to conquer love
okay. And so all the wrong people ask you to help them. Do you know what I mean?
And all the people you find difficult and that's for you to conquer yourself and
to let love be the dominant. So do the blessed in heaven not lose anything
everything to love. In the same way the more she advances she is the soul the
less she feels the very crafting of the virtues because she's no longer
struggling to be patient and kind because investing them all love converts
them all into itself keeping them at rest within itself like many noble
princesses working itself alone and giving life to them all. And while the soul
does not perceive them in love she finds them all but more beautiful more pure
more perfect more ennobled because they are fed from the noblest source which is
divine love. And if she does perceive them it's a sign that they are separated
from love. He says if you still notice that you're practicing
patience then you haven't got to this stage because if you were at that stage
patience would be drawn up into love and and you would say to someone I'm not
being patient I'm just loving them. I'm not being kind I'm just loving them I'm
not being humble I'm just loving them because everything becomes love and since
God is love that's where the whole spiritual life is going. That's the most
beautiful summary of the journey of the spiritual life. So he then he gives us
an example. A soul receives a command and she exercises obedience to obey the
person in order to acquire the virtue to sacrifice her own will and for many
other reasons. Now by doing so she already perceives that she's exercising
obedience she feels the toil and the sacrifice that this virtue brings with
itself. And other than obeys not to obey the person not for other reasons but
knowing that God would be displeased by her disobedience she looks at God in the
one who commands her and for the love of him she sacrifices herself and obeys.
This is a very very good example summary I should say of the life of St.
Teresa of Lissue in the convent. All her obedience was love everything she did for
love and so the second one is not obeying to practice the virtue of
obedience they're obeying to love God. So in this the soul does not perceive
that she obeys but only that she loves and because she has obeyed only out of
love otherwise she would have disobeyed anyway and so with all the rest.
Therefore courage along the journey because the more you move forward the
sooner you will enjoy in advance and also down here down here means on earth the
eternal beatitude of soul and true love. In other words you will already
experience heaven on earth and the difference between heaven and earth when
you arrive at this summit of love is that you can still merit and the folks in
heaven can no longer merit because their journey is finished and because your
journey is not finished you can actually grow greater than them. It's amazing so
October the 18th 1905 everything is in increasing love and remaining close to
Jesus so big heading love is everything love is the issue. This morning as I was
in my usual state Jesus came all of a sudden and told me my daughter what
foolishness even in holy things they think of how to content themselves. Now I
don't know if you have an example but I've given retreats for 40 years and it's
a PhD in how human beings are and I would bring all these holy people to a
retreat house in different countries not just this one and all these people
coming full of religion and full of holiness and wanting to grow and
holiness and everything they want the best rooms. They complain
handsomely if there aren't all the gadgets and everything that they expect
in the room. Will they shift a room to help somebody who has actually got a
need? No I paid for it. They come down to the dining room they want the best
food they want total variety they complain if the portions aren't big enough. I
remember one gentleman I understand he was bigger than me okay and he was
sitting beside me at the table and he complained that the portions weren't
big enough I said can't you should have sat beside me he would have had at
least one and a half dinners every day. I said you're complaining to the wrong
person God doesn't supply the dinners I said I could have done something about
it. This is too late keep your complaint to yourself. They want the front seats
in the synagogue and they want the best seats and they still want
spirituality and they still want to grow and holiness and they don't know
they're blocking it with every move they make and if I tell them we're going
to have a day of fasting we paid so the only way I ever got them to fast was to
do an all-night vigil in which they weren't fasting at all but at least
they were fasting from bed. No you learn a lot when you give retreats to the
human beings learn a lot and the main thing you learn is that while we say we
want God we want him on a cushion we don't want him at a price now the people
who are going to get places are the ones who will take him at a price like
Louisa. If the only thing you have are nails and across I'll have them. Mactimilian
Colby was told by our blessed mother she could have two crowns. One was the
crown of purity and holiness and the priesthood and the other was the
crown of march and we said I'll have the two. It was only six and he got the two.
It's the people who really really want God and I haven't yet seen the holy
people in Ireland really really want God. They want him and now I'm not
looking at you or anything you just happen to be in front of me. It applies
to every single one of us in the country because if all of us wanted God at any
cost we would turn back the tide of evil overnight. So something major still has
to happen to us and I wouldn't have said it only came up here. But you see the
wonderful thing about this text is it allows me to say a lot you know so
even in holy things they want to content themselves. I remember in one
particular retreat in another country for your off the hook when I really had to
ask a religious sister to please please cooperate in the way we were praying.
She would run ahead of everybody else and there was no way she would just pray in
harmony with us. No she did. God walked out left the retreat. I said that woman
has a vow of obedience. God help her superior. Would not, oh never mind. But I
did want to illustrate this in case you think that it wasn't a serious thing
that he was saying because our problem is that we wanted to easy. I remember the
very first seminar that Tony Hickey gave in my house on divine will and we were
all as green as grass. Okay about divine will and at the first chance he got you
know for us to have questions and everything. He said anybody got questions
and one hand shut up and the question was is there a shortcut? That's us. We want
to get there without paying the price. We want to get on the train and have the
journey but we don't want to pay the ticket and that actually makes the
difference between saints and people who don't become saints. That's what he says
here. My daughter bought foolishness even in holy things they think of how to
content themselves. If in holy things they make me flee where shall I find a
place in the actions of my human creatures? What a mistake. When everything is in
anticipating the actions of love everything is in loving God and loving
your neighbor. Jesus said it the whole law and the prophets hangs on it. In executing
these actions and in gathering as many things as possible in order to increase
love that's your Ephesians 3 text again. And remaining very close to me to drink
at the spring of my love and to immerse oneself completely in my love. What a
blunder he said they do everything differently. Now this was said in 1905 so
it wasn't actually written entirely for you. It was written for human beings who
think that they're seeking God and in actual fact they're seeking themselves.
Isn't it sad? I remember having a terrible experience in a church in
Canada. I was giving a retreat in the parish. So I was the the invited speaker
and so I used to go into the church early in the morning when the church was
empty. It's when I love churches when they're empty to have my prayer time with
the Lord and there I was giving all my attention to the Lord and I just sat
wherever I sat. I mean the church was empty. You know next thing I got this
ferocious dig in the shoulder and a very angry voice female said that's my
place. I looked at her and I said the church is empty. That is my place. I said
do you know who's there in the tabernacle? I stood with the Lord who's here and for
the third time very angrily that is my place. She was coming to Mass. I don't
have to tell you I got up. I went as far as possible. I wait more. I don't know
what she felt when I got up to give the talk.
Well it was it was the attitude. I mean you don't walk into a church in anger
demanding a particular spot but we do don't we? It's not the only place in the
planet where I've had to shift with somebody else's place and it's this
thing that we demand to have certain things and we say we're not attached to
anything but I know people in in most parishes I have visited who are very
attached to the particular place in the seat and they haven't shifted out of
that for 20 years and if you try to shift them accidentally have good life
insurance. No it's sad because they're they say they're seeking God and they're
not. That's why Jesus says what a mistake. What a blunder. You go to stop
there. Do you see why these early volumes are really necessary for us to
pick up on lots of stuff that we need to pick up on? That we're accidentally
blocking the way. We don't mean to but that's actually what we're doing.